never expected to be sitting in front of
the cameras but that's what a remarkable
story of survival does for you the 57
year old a retired carpenter who finds
even walking difficult survived in the
water for 28 hours after being washed
out to sea he ended up eight miles from
home and told us his faith got him
through
the most scariest part
to me during the ordeal was
when the waves took me from land into
the sea
what came into my mind when i was
helpless
at city were two things
one
that i still had faith in god
two
is my family and i i only remembered
what uh
how my family would think
at that moment maybe
he died
much of his home island of a tata was
destroyed by the tsunami that hit tonga
still his hope is to go back
everything is gone
but my heart
is at atata
and i was raised there my parents are
raised are buried there
and i will go back there one day
inspiring stories are one thing the
practical needs are urgent the arrival
then of the first aid flights packed
with water shelter generators and
communications equipment was a welcome
sight in tonga on the runway locals
spent days clearing a volcanic ash by
hand
the protective gear evidence of the
effort to make sure they don't bring
cove it as well
lizala falau now has the nickname
aquaman after a movie he says he's never
seen the real life experiences of nature
he says are plenty
no man can withstand the power of nature
what we need to understand is
how we react
when it comes
how do we treat it when it comes
for me
i just want to be cool
to be calm
when it comes
he seems to have succeeded